je le disais en début de cette nuit nous
avons avec nous Charles Rodwell qui est
député de la première circonscription
des Yvelines on va parler avec vous de
ce rapport à cette mission parlementaire
autour de l'export et de l'attractivité
économique l'actualité récente forcément
aussi pour pour démarrer hein c'est
débats qui sont achevés vendredi autour
de la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte qui va
être débattu désormais au Sénat en
première lecture deux semaines de débat
on peut le dire pour le moins houleuse
avec beaucoup de violences on a vu
beaucoup de violence dans cette émission
sans discussion aussi autour de cet
article phare de la réforme qui est
l'article 7 qui est bien fait ce report
de l'âge légal à 64 ans les guêpe de
départ à la retraite du coup le bilan il
est plutôt négatif après c'est ces deux
semaines de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale quel bilan voudrait c'est moi
je regrette qu'on ne soit pas allé au
bout du texte notamment au bout de cet
article l'article 7 on a été empêché par
un blocage
de débat parlementaire par une
obstruction parlementaire par deux
collègues si vous voulez je veux pas
revenir sur toutes les polémiques qui a
eu ces dernières semaines on les a tous
vu chacun d'entre nous moi ce que je
regrette c'est que du fait de la
majorité relative depuis plusieurs mois
la somme de la nationale revient un peu
sous le coup des projecteurs et les
débats qu'on a à la fois les médias vous
les journalistes mais aussi chaque
citoyen disent on regarde une partie des
débats parlementaires et depuis le début
de la législature je crois qu'on a quand
même montré sur un certain nombre de
textes très important la protection
sanitaire le pouvoir d'achat l'assurance
chômage les énergies renouvelables qu'on
a su débattre en étant souvent en
désaccord en désaccord parfois
importants mais en trouvant des
majorités en trouvant du consensus
et le spectacle qui a été celui de
l'Assemblée nationale pendant la réforme
des retraites pendant le texte qu'on a
étudié n'a absolument pas montré cela et
à montrer tout l'inverse moi je pense
que c'est la responsabilité d'une part
de nos collègues sur le sujet mais je
pense qu'on a une responsabilité tous
collective de retrouver la sérénité
qu'on a eu dans le débat depuis le début
du quinquennat au service en fait tout
simplement des Français qui nous ont
élus alors c'est un moment confus à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que dans le
même temps les manifestations sont
plutôt bien déroulées dans la rue pas
d'incident à remonter c'est monter à
plus de 2,5 millions de manifestants
selon la CGT les syndicats qui appellent
à une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
une grande journée de mobilisation le 7
mars prochain comment avancer justement
dans cette séquence alors qu'il y a
quand même une contestation autour de ce
projet il y a un récent sondage un livre
sauce teria qui faisait têtard quand
même de 64% de Français qui seraient
opposés à ce texte de la réforme des
retraites moi je souhaiterais juste
revenir sur le rôle que les syndicats
ont joué et le rendre un hommage moi je
suis coupable à la réforme des retraites
une bonne partie des syndicats la CFDT
la CGT Force ouvrière en tête ils sont
opposés mais je veux vraiment leur
rendre hommage sur la manière dont elles
ont mené les manifestations dans le
calme dans la sérénité sont des bords
malgré la radicalisation qu'appelait
certains mouvements politiques en France
je pense notamment à l'extrême gauche
ils ne sont pas tombés dans ce piège ils
ont fait entendre leur voix en
manifestants dans le calme la deuxième
chose pour laquelle je voudrais le
rendre hommage c'est la concertation le
dialogue n'a jamais été rompu entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats et si on a
pu améliorer le texte sur la pénibilité
sur les carrières dites hachées c'est un
mot que je n'aime pas mais qui décrit
une réalité sur la prise en compte du
droit des femmes sur la prise en compte
des carrières longues c'est en grande
partie grâce au rôle que les syndicats
ont joué à la fois dans la manifestation
mais aussi dans la concertation qui est
dans le gouvernement encore une fois je
vous le répète je ne partage pas leur
avis mais je leur rends cet hommage qui
je crois participe à une sérénité autour
de ce débat j'imagine Christian Aubert
vous qui est faite partie du monde
agricole qu'on regarde aussi cette
séquence avec intérêt cette séquence
autour de la réforme des retraites oui
on regarde ça d'assez loin puisque
finalement le meilleur agricole
travaille longtemps sans forcément
regarder l'âge au départ de retraite
mais oui alors après aussi la retraite à
l'école est une des plus faibles donc
finalement on va les acteurs cotisent
quand même travail dur toute leur année
et finalement on arrive dans le fameux
minima nécessaire donc il y a eu des
pistes mais bon il y a peut-être encore
un petit travail à faire sur le minimum
vieillesse alors on date de loin mais
je partage totalement votre avis
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a décidé la
suppression des régimes spéciaux et pour
le coup c'est une partie du texte qu'on
a voté à l'assemblée mais tout
simplement parce que il y a certaines
professions pour lesquelles le régime
est structuellement déficitaire
aujourd'hui il y a plus d'agriculteurs à
la retraite que d'agricul qui
travaillent et donc si le régime
dépendait uniquement des agriculteurs il
faudrait vous demander de payer des
cotisations absolument astronomiques ou
alors il faudrait demander aux
agriculteurs à la retraite d'avoir une
pension encore plus faible nous l'idée
qu'on défend du régime des retraites
c'est dire qu'on a un régime général qui
permet à tous d'avoir un minimum
vieillesse un minimum retraite à
carrière complète à au minimum 1200
euros et pour cela lançons des
travailleurs quel que soit leur
profession doivent contribuer à ce
régime général pour permettre à tout le
monde d'avoir un minimum retraite c'est
l'idée de la réforme que je défends et
je comprends qu'on soit pas d'accord le
débat parlementaire doit exister pour ça
j'espère qu'il redeviendra plus serein
pour qu'on puisse débattre de cette
question le texte maintenant est très
examiné par par les sénateurs alors
au-delà des travaux parlementaires sur
la réforme des retraites vous avez
travaillé récemment je le disais tout à
l'heure Charles Rodwell sur les
dispositifs de soutien à l'export et à
la tractivité économique et vous avez
rendu vos conclusions tout récemment
puisque c'était à la à la fin janvier
alors c'est une mission parlementaire
avait confié avec une autre députée
députée de l'opposition et de la France
insoumise Sofia à chikiru bah comment ça
s'est passé justement la collaboration
écoutez elle sait très bien passé
justement parce qu'on a des avis
divergents et c'est ça qui est
merveilleux dans le travail
parlementaire c'est que hors champ des
caméras et or émissaire il y a un vrai
travail approfondi qui se fait entre les
parlementaires qui ont des avis
totalement différents CE fishikiru est
membre du groupe de la France insoumise
je suis membre du groupe Renaissance et
pourtant 90% des propositions que nous
avons faites nous avons fait des
propositions en commun on a des
désaccords majeurs sur la fiscalité sur
les investissements étrangers en France
mais on a aussi trouvé des points
d'accord pourquoi parce que comment se
mène une mission parlementaire elle se
mène en auditionnant les sachants les
services de l'état des élus locaux les
collectivités locales les entreprises et
leurs salariés à travers les fédérations
interprofessionnelles les entreprises
yvelinoises on a interrogé des dizaines
et des dizaines surprise de la
circonscription à la fois par des
échanges informels par un vrai une vraie
table ronde qu'on a formé à l'Assemblée
nationale que j'allais vous demander
qu'est-ce qu'une mission parlementaire
c'est des auditions finalement sur un
sujet on interroge les sachants sur un
sujet on initier sur un sujet en disant
il faut trouver des solutions sur ce
sujet on interroge l'ensemble des partis
prenantes les acteurs publics les
acteurs privés les acteurs nationaux les
acteurs locaux on les interroge sur les
solutions que eux rencontrent
concrètement dans leur vie quotidienne
et ensuite nous regardons ensemble nous
les parlementaires comment est-ce qu'on
peut amender la loi comment est-ce qu'on
peut conseiller le gouvernement pour
faire voler une partie de l'action au
service des entreprises le gouvernement
et les acteurs locaux on a visité une
entreprise qui s'appelle prodways à
Montigny-bretonneux une pépite une
pépite industrielle et on l'a visité
avec qui avec le sous-préfieux
développement économique avec le
président de la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie Guillaume quiraux avec le
président l'agglomération Jean-Michel
fourgus et sa directrice de
développement économique avec le maire
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux Laurent
mercière pourquoi les collectivement
mais tout simplement parce que chaque
acteur que je viens de citer un rôle clé
à jouer pour soutenir nos entreprises à
l'export et pour soutenir la
réindustrialisation de chaque
département en France et c'est ce
travail collectif en commun c'est par ce
travail qu'on y arrivera le
parlementaire tout seul il peut rien
faire donc c'est un travail collectif
pour mener à bien cette mission qui part
on le disait d'un constat un paradoxe
avec ce déficit commercial record en
France un 154 milliards d'euros alors
même que la France a un reste le pays
européen le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers et du coup
qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté sur le
terrain il y a quand même une audition
auprès d'une trentaine d'entreprises
qu'est-ce qu'il en est ressorté est-ce
que les dispositifs fonctionnent bien
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
peut-être dans leur fonctionnement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en avez
conclu et qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
observer la principale conclusion qu'on
a tiré sur le terrain
exporter nos produits à l'étranger doit
s'inscrire au cœur de notre stratégie
industrielle depuis cinq ans on a lancé
un syndrome de politiques pour
réindustrialiser notre pays donc
reproduire en France dans tous les
domaines que ce soit dans le secteur
agroalimentaire et agricole que soit
dans le 7 l'automobile que ce soit dans
le secteur de l'industrie lourde et
l'autre technologie du nucléaire de de
l'aéronautique et d'autres et pour
pouvoir relancer l'export il faut que au
bout de la chaîne on propose à nos
entreprises de vendre leurs produits à
l'étranger et qu'au début de la chaîne
on propose à des investisseurs étrangers
de venir en France et de continuer à
investir dans nos entreprises en faisant
bien attention que ces investissements
ne viennent pas à l'encontre de nos
intérêts nationaux c'est pour ça qu'il
faut renforcer les contrôles mais
comment est-ce qu'on fait à la fois par
la loi mais aussi départements par
département ville parvine commune par
commune entreprise par entreprise c'est
la raison pour laquelle le département
est les communes ont un rôle clé à jouer
dans le domaine je parlais tout à
l'heure des Yvelines l'enjeu national
l'enjeu français c'est en enjeu
yvelinois on a quand même un paradoxe
dans ce département qu'il y a jamais eu
autant de création d'entreprises 22000
entreprises créées en 2022 et en même
temps rien que le département des
Yvelines c'est 10 milliards d'euros de
déficit commercial donc tout le travail
que font les conseils départementaux les
présidents d'intercaux les maires les
parlementaires quand on se saisit du
sujet pour soutenir nos entreprises pour
les mettre en lien pour leur permettre
de produire et enfin pour leur permettre
d'exporter c'est comme ça entreprise par
entreprise qu'on va pouvoir répondre à
cet enjeu c'est la conviction que j'ai
et c'est la conviction que je crois
partage macora porteur sur la mission
malgré nos désaccord politique nationaux
c'est très rapidement la suite
maintenant est-ce que ça pourrait
conduire à des évolutions concrètes on a
fait un certain nombre de propositions
30 propositions dans le projet qui vont
de mesures législatives jusqu'à des
propositions d'expérimentation donc des
mécanismes qu'on voudrait tester moi
j'aimerais que les Yvelines soient en
département test sur le sujet en tout
cas c'est les échanges que nous avons
aujourd'hui pour porter ses propositions
et pour les mettre en oeuvre alors dans
l'actualité il y a aussi une autre
mesure on parle d'un tout autre sujet
par le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin c'est la suppression des 12
points sur le permis de conduire pour
les personnes qui prennent le volant
sous emprise de drogue ou d'alcool le
débat et sur la table il est revenu sur
la table avec le grave accident qui est
impliqué à l'humoriste Pierre Palmade il
y a quelques jours alors dans l'émission
PAF elle l'avocat au Barreau de
Versailles Geoffrey Meyer et revenu sur
sur cette mesure sur cette annonce pour
lui elle existe déjà cette mesure n'est
pas forcément
utile on écoute Geoffrey Meyer tout de
suite ce que veut faire Gérald Darmanin
c'est générer une automaticité sur le
retrait du permis de conduire
l'invalidation pour des faux de points
dans l'hypothèse ou une personne aurait
conduit en étant sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants mais en réalité la loi
prévoit déjà cette possibilité lorsque
vous êtes lorsque vous êtes contrôlé
après avoir conduit sous l'emprise de
stupéfiant vous êtes donc passible d'une
comparution devant le tribal
correctionnel et vous avez aussi la
possibilité de faire l'objet d'une
rétention de votre permis de conduire
par décision préfectorale donc cette
décision est ce dispositif existe déjà
le tribunal correctionnel lorsqu'il est
saisi par le procureur de la République
après que une personne ait été contrôlée
en ayant conduit après avoir consommé
des stupéfiants peut tout à fait
prononcer une annulation du permis de
conduire on est à livrer ceci d'ailleurs
cette mesure existe déjà donc je pense
que Gérald Darmanin est en train
tranquillement de ce présidentialiser et
il reprend un petit peu les vieilles
recettes qui avaient fonctionné et surf
sur la vague de l'émotion qui a été
générée par l'accident causé par Pierre
Palmade mais en tout cas cette mesure
est à mon avis de mesure premièrement
inutile sur le plan juridique et
judiciaire parce que les dispositions
existent déjà et que deuxièmement
effectivement
peut s'interroger sur le bien fondé en
matière de société et de santé de de
cette de cette mesure là je suis une
réaction rapide je vous ferai meilleur
dit que ça existe déjà dans le reste
qu'il faut aller plus loin à votre avis
sur ce sujet à des personnes qui
conduisent sous l'emprise de drogue de
d'alcool alors Gérald Darmanin aussi
fait une autre proposition c'est de
supprimer le retrait d'un point au
permis pour les petits excès de vitesse
à ce inférieur ou égal à 5 km/h moi je
ne partage absolument pas les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus tant sur
l'intention que sur les faits ce
monsieur vient d'exprimer lui-même que
la suppression ou le retrait du permis
était
dépendait d'une décision d'une gestion
préfectorale ce que propose générale
Darmanin c'est tout simplement que le
retrait soit automatique pourquoi si tu
mesures de justice quand vous prenez la
voiture sous emprise vous êtes un danger
public et vous causer des dangers de
mort
on l'a vu récemment donc il est
parfaitement normal que lorsque vous
prenez votre voiture sous emprise de la
drogue votre permis soit retiré et à
l'inverse le sujet des travailleurs il y
a des millions de Français qui vont
travailler tous les jours en voiture et
qui n'ont pas d'autres choix ce que
propose Gérald Darmanin c'est sert de
les sanctionner lorsqu’un lorsqu'il y a
un excès de vitesse mais de prendre en
compte la situation de chacun dans le
domaine oui il faut les sanctionner
quand il y a un excès de vitesse mais
oui il faut aussi mieux prendre en
compte le fait qu'il y a des millions de
Français qui vont travailler en voiture
tous les jours c'est le sens de la
deuxième mesure qu'il fait quant à la
première il est évident que le retrait
doit être automatique lorsque quelqu'un
est un danger public sur la route merci
Charles ordwell d'avoir répondu à tous
ces sujets je rappelle que vous êtes le
député de la première circonscription
des unes suivra bien sûr la suite des
événements pour pour ce rapport que et
ses conclusions que vous avez rendu à la
fin janvier autour de l'export et de
l'attractivité économique merci d'avoir
été avec nous